i love your work and i have to say i'm
getting a lot of points
from my daughter and my daughter's
friends because they adore you
okay that feels good that feels like
genuine points for me
no it really does uh they could care
less about anything i'm ever up to
uh because uh you know obvious reasons
i'm
95 years old but you they adore
and they were really excited that i was
talking to you today and i think a cat
just creeped up behind you
that i i thought all the cats had exited
the room i apologize
no don't apologize um what's the cat's
name
this is twinkie tweaky yes
as in someone's a little tweaky because
they've been on meth for a while that
kind of tweaky
exactly well you're lovely of a lovely
way with animals
you know i'd ask you a question i did
some research on you and
uh you were a hair stylist before you
got into comedy
i was and uh you still
do you still do it do you still like
work on people's hair and i'm asking for
a reason
i've grown mine out as you can see
it's it's really there we go
it's got a flop it's got a fly is that
what the technical term is it's a flop
well you know what i would actually say
the technical term is
and the last time i cut hair was last
year pre-quarantined
i gave my husband a haircut and i gave
him
the brandon frazier mummy cut and i
think that's what you have right now
this is right this is what it is this is
the brennan fraser mummy cut
yes because it's like it was kind of a
bowl but you know
center part yours is a little off-center
but it kind of did that like
little mushroom to the sides which was
cool in 97 or eight
i was cool in 97 98 you were ends up
perfectly
yes i like it